are you curious about how the VFX was
done on the Last of Us you'd be
surprised to find out that over the
course of 18 months 535 VFX shots were
captured with a crew of 650 people and
most of the time Bella and Pedro were
acting in front of blue screens in a
more or less empty set so how did they
get it to be so smooth well let's find
out one of the most utilized techniques
in the show when you're looking at all
those moss-covered slanted buildings the
disheveled cityscape or even the highway
Joel and Ellie traveled on that seemed a
little too empty yeah that was all blue
screen and I gotta give props to Bella
Ramsay when they were gazing off at the
skyline in the Firefly Hospital Wing
they were literally just staring at a
blank blue screen talking about how
Stellar The View was but man you can't
deny that view luckily there weren't any
infected rushing up to ruin the moment
speaking of let's talk prosthetic I
don't know about you but I love
practical effects especially when Barry
gowers involved like if you're a
stranger things fan you might recognize
his name he's responsible for the
prosthetic look of the season 4 villain
vechna Berry designed the Prosthetics
that gave us the clickers but didn't
stray very far from Neil druckman's
original designs for the video game we
started off with a lot of preliminary
concept art
we were using that as a stepping stone
and the clickers were also just a bunch
of actors who were huge fans of the
video game they were familiar with the
movements of the clickers so they were
more than stoked to get plastered with
prosthetics and get into character as
one I found them sort of beautiful they
were beautiful luckily for them though
they didn't have to get a full body
prosthetic cast like Adam basil AKA our
resident bloater one of the most
difficult infected enemies in the game
like I couldn't wait to see it on screen
the bloater was actually a six foot six
stunt man named Adam basil and the
costume he was wearing it was a full 80
pounds like of course there was a little
bit of CGI sprinkled on in
post-production to polish it off but
Adam was in full-on bloater mode
underneath a ton of latex and foam
rubber so the first step to get the
costume was to take a cast of Basil's
entire body and then follow that up with
modeling clay to create the Prosthetics
genome Acevedo who worked on the Lord of
the Rings franchise was also heavily
involved in the bloater design he
figured out all of the proportions some
of the growths on the body and used
references from the game and combined
them with what was able to be
practically made with a prosthetic suit
what did you think of the bloater reveal
do you think they should have used more
CGI like it's clear they have the skills
for it so obviously the blue screen
isn't a magic canvas that creates
Landscapes and scenes on its own it
requires major creative skills to create
those buildings and Landscapes so there
were three main techniques a build of
full CGI destroyed City buildings a
build of non-destroyed buildings that
could be used to simulate various
destruction States and of course a huge
Reliance on matte painting with camera
projection mapping so often those three
techniques would be like combined to
create scenes like the state house
explosion but one thing you might be
surprised about that wasn't digitally
created the giraffe was a real animal
actor named nabo that doesn't mean there
weren't ton of visual effects in the
scene though like the setup alone took
an entire month it was mostly so the
giraffe could get comfortable in a
different environment surrounded by a
bunch of new people so yeah the giraffe
was real but the environment was not it
was fully created with CGI and like it
was one of the most complicated scenes
to capture the visual effect supervisor
Alex Wayne isolated the giraffe on set
as well as the extra giraffes in the
background so that everything else in
the background could be computer
generated so like it's hard to tell
while watching the show what CGI and
what's not especially when it came to
the city's digital map the reason why
all of the digital mappings look so real
and on point is because they used actual
photography from all those cities to
create the digital layout like the
visual effects team brought on
specifically for the show's environment
took scheduling photography trips to
Boston so they would have every exact
reference they need they studied
abandoned structures collapsed buildings
and vehicles that have been exposed to
the elements and analyzed exactly how
degradation happens under different
conditions they used all these
references to create the digital world
we got to see on the show not without
major struggle in some areas though so
easily one of the most difficult
environmental shots to bring to life
this was the scene at the beginning of
episode 2 that they called The Hair
Salon scene the scene was complex
because they felt that they needed an
awe-inspiring moment when Ellie walks
out into open daylight as we all see the
city for the first time the visual
effects team was forced to think outside
the box here as every building was
meticulously damaged and detailed and
they also had to study the lighting in
that particular location of the city to
be able to replicate it with CGI it was
really tough stuff that is easily
overlooked by the Casual viewer The Last
of Us without VFX is still majorly
impressive the use of prosthetics for
the clicker and the bloaters is insane
and terrifying while the CGI for all of
these skylines and buildings is so
smooth you'd really have no idea how
much movie Magic is involved and like I
was also happy to find out that the
giraffe wasn't CGI just a brilliant
actor so what's your favorite visual
effect from the show
thank you